allez tout de suite on va accueillir
quelqu'un que vous attendez depuis très
très longtemps il est avec nous ce soir
à saint géry fox
alors comment ça va ça va très bien et
vous mon bel animateur à la peau d'ébène
alors bien sûr sur jamie foxx train de
jouer on va faire quoi alors nous allons
jouer tous ensemble ou là on va faire
quoi alors nous allons jouer avec mon
pianiste pineau la race track jouer de
la survie et ça c'est que là aussi vous
lever la main le plus rapide ça comptera
donc pour le contrôle de fin d'année
alors attention on va jouer avec quoi
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui nous
allons devoir deviner des personnalités
au sein de chorégraphies que j'ai
réalisé moi même bien sûr un hommage à
maurice béjart allez on y va
est-ce que je peux avoir s'il vous plaît
le grand grand grand conteur silva merci
beaucoup attention c'est parti je me
sens tellement bien avec vous merci
merci sont libres je me sens libre c'est
très bien alors nous allons démarrer
bien sûr avec une position du mont chéri
voici la première questions du quiz de
jimmy foxtrot
bonsoir c'est une chanteuse ça
libertines et désenchanté tuerk twelfth
et l'icône de la gay pride mais aussi
des coiffeurs visagistes ainsi que des
skis mois que telfrance battue elle m'a
tendu la main
et sont sans toit c'est des freins mais
nos gentils plus
alors séjour à calmer la main en premier
et non est ce que vous avez trouvé
non enora les i mylène farmer avait
défoncé manager vous êtes chez vous avec
sept places et une deuxième personne est
de nationalité djibril je vous demande
et marcato difficile c'est cyril vos
blacks
alors nous allons démarrer position du
tire fesses flexion des jambes à 70
degrés on sort la perche et on ne
s'assoit pas allez c'est parti ça va on
a compris
musique / un jazz flamenco voici la
deuxième question du quiz de jimmy
foxtrot pour toi c'est un animateur télé
il aime les clashs et les vases tamek
flamenco données il animait une émission
qui portait son nom mais qui a été
déprogrammée
ap donc tu la briette avec le mans
series ticket entre chats entre chats il
a le même temps
cheney est déjà en faïence de salle de
bains garage à vélos
alors qu'est ce que vous avez dit
lacroix
il a le même temps qu'une tranches de
cheddar et des noms en faïence de salle
de bain vous avez trouvé je pense que
c'est jean marc morandini c'est quoi
c'est ça bonne réponse de positive
dernière allait dernier c'est une autre
personnalité qu'on doit trouver une
rationalité nous avons démarré bien
évidemment donné la position position
des toilettes turques par marc et à la
pression et la lecture que main droite
sur la paroi de droite mal gauche sur la
paroi de gauche génuflexion à 70 degrés
et on sort le pied pour tenir la porte
et bien cette musique s'il vous plaît
sur une salsa mambo douati but carajas
vélo voici la dernière questions du quiz
de jimmy foxtrot
c'est un animateur radio sacha rotative
qui l'animé grosses têtes sur rtl nambo
mambo chihuahua quand les gars l'ont
gêné qu'il est il a bien connu du temps
bert jammaer père mais aussi des ballons
des derniers dinosaures
l'équipe u à droite moitié plus à gauche
il fait les costumes chez petit bateau
grand écart america
agen
c'est pour les débats philippe bouvard
c'est bien ça pas de réponse du brushing
sur des 17 à partir de la diva sur tous
les matins bien sûr on le sait la
navarre exceptionnel